>> CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS ARE
CALLING ON PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
DECLARE HEALTH EMERGENCY DUE TO
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF
RESPIRATORY AND FLU INFECTIONS.
BIDEN OFFICIAL SAYS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS, QUOTE, READY
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES IN NEED OF HEALTH
ON A CASE-BY-CASE BASIS.
OR TO REACT IS MEDICAL
CONTRIBUTOR DOCTOR MARTY.
LET'S GET INTO THE SITUATION
THAT IMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
SUPPRESSED, IMMUNE SYSTEMS ARE
SUPPRESSED BECAUSE OF THE
VACCINE, DO YOU THINK THAT IS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE SITUATION?
>> I DO AND A LOT OF DOCTORS
BELIEVE IN THE CONCEPT OF
IMMUNITY DEBT, WHEN YOU'RE --
YOU ARE SHELTERED, YOUR BODIES
NOT GETTING THAT LOW LEVEL OF
VIRAL EXPOSURE THAT BUILDS
IMMUNITY AT A LOW LEVEL AND IT
MAY BE SUBCLINICAL, YOU MAY NOT
NOTICE IT.
THAT IS PROBABLY WHY WE ARE
SEEING THIS MASSIVE INFLUX OF
OUR SVN INFLUENZA AND OTHER
INFECTIONS ACCOUNTING FOR
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN CHILDREN.
RACHEL: IS THIS SOMETHING
DOCTORS KNOW BUT NOBODY IS
OFFICIALLY SAYING IT BECAUSE IT
MAY BE POLITICALLY INCORRECT?
>> THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SUPPORT
FOR SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IN THE WORLD OF CENSORSHIP IN
THE MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT BUT
MANY IMMUNOLOGISTS HAVE WRITTEN
ABOUT THIS, INFECTIOUS DISEASE
SPECIALISTS, IT'S WELL KNOWN,
THE CONCEPT OF IMMUNITY DEBT.
THIS MAY BE ONE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE LOCKDOWN
WE'VE NOT YET MEASURED AND ARE
SEEING THESE HOSPITALIZATIONS
IN MASS NUMBERS, TALKING 90-95%
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN CHILDREN
ARE NOT FOR COVID BUT OTHER
INFECTIONS.
RACHEL: WHAT'S THIS DOING TO
THE COURT ABILITY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE PEDIATRIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION, YOU SAY
THEIR LEADERS ARE ACTIVISTS AND
ARE DISCONNECTED FROM THEIR
MEMBERS.
>> THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS LOST A LOT OF
CREDIBILITY IN BEING BY
STANDARDS IN THE SCHOOL
CLOSURES, INSISTING EVERY CHILD
WEAR A MASK FOR 2 YEARS
COVERING THEIR FACES AND NOW WE
ARE DEALING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND LIFELONG LEARNING
LOST SO MANY PEDIATRICIANS
STOPPED PAYING THEIR DUES TO
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS.
A SURVEY SHOWED 40% OF
PEDIATRIC PEDIATRICIANS IN
AMERICA DID NOT RECOMMEND COVID
VACCINE FOR YOUNG HEALTHY
CHILDREN, THAT SHOWS THE
MASSIVE DISCONNECT WITH THE
ACTIVIST LEADERSHIP OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY.
RACHEL: YOU SHOWED COURAGE WHEN
IT COUNTED.
I WISH MANY DOCTORS THAT AREN'T
PAYING THEIR DUES AND THAT
THEIR VOICES BE HEARD WHEN IT
ACTUALLY COUNTED.
I WANT TO MOVE QUICKLY TO
ANOTHER TOPIC, RESEARCHERS SAY
THERE MAY BE A VACCINE EDEN FOR
FENTANYL, A DRUG THAT IS 100
TIMES STRONGER THAN MORPHINE,
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> INTERESTING RESEARCH FROM
HOUSTON, THIS IDEA THAT IF YOU
GIVE THE VACCINE ANTIBODIES
COULD DEVELOP TO FENTANYL
MAKING THE MOLECULE LARGER AND
IT CANNOT ENTER THE BLOOD BRAIN
BARRIER AND HAVE AS MUCH OF AN
EFFECT SO THIS IS INTERESTING.
IT MAY MAKE FENTANYL A LITTLE
SAFER BUT WHEN YOU MAKE DRUGS A
LITTLE SAFER PEOPLE PUSH THE
RISK LEVEL AND RISK APPEALS TO
SOME PEOPLE, THAT'S WHY THE
BEST STRATEGY IS NO DRUG IS
SAFE, WE CAN'T PROMOTE THE
MORAL HAZARD OF A SAFER DRUG.
RACHEL: THE SOLUTION IS TO
CLOSE THE SOUTHERN BORDER WHERE